beekeeper Arvind knows that when left on
its own
the humble bumble has a trick up its
sleeve she bears very well aware as she
goes through hardship that man two and a
half minutes later you work yourself
free I don't know why but this is both
cute I'm scary at the same time how did
this bee pull off this amazing escape
act abuse stinger is composed of a
stabilizing rod which is connected to a
venom bulb at one end and tapers into a
Stinger at the other end on either side
of the stabilizing rod are two
retractable blades that alternately saw
back and forth into Arvin's skin wedging
the stinger further into his skin honey
bee stingers have evolved to sting other
insects that don't have elastic
properties in the skin and this means
they can easily pull their stingers out
once they've done the stinging the same
is not true when they sting us the
stingers actually get stuck in there and
it makes it very difficult for the bees
to pull them out after now ordinarily
when a bee stings a person the person
will probably try to swat the bee which
makes the bee want to fly away ripping
itself in half and leaving both the
stinger and the venom sac which can
continue to pump venom for up to 10
minutes because Arvind is a beekeeper
he's very calm and he's quite used to
the presence of these bees and he's even
used to getting stung so he doesn't
panic he simply leaves the bees to
Twitter stingers out further further
further until they finally dislodged
themselves and fly off so next time you
get stung by one of these buzzing beasts
remember give her time and she'll be
fine